I thought we could do
an experiment here today.
I asked you if we could try it
and see what happens.
I'm quite fascinated by
the Saga Norén character.
I don't think she knows,
but many believe she's got Asperger's.
If I understand it correctly,
it makes her quite direct.
For instance,
she doesn't understand irony.
There are these sides to her.
It seems like
it's easy for you to become her.
-So I thought, what if she had my job?
-Yes...
Do you understand? What if there was
a Saga Norén talk show?
Yes... Okay.
She's been fired from her police job.
She's trying to make a living
as a talk show host.
Many are impressed that she managed
to get a job as a police officer.
-So am I.
-She could have got this job as well.
-Yes... She's not scared to ask.
-Let's give it a go.
There's your notepad.
I don't know what you are going to ask.
-But I will answer.
-Yes. Okay.
Now you can introduce
the Saga Norén show.
Hello! Today we will interview
this person. His name is Skavlan.
-How many kids do you have?
-I've got four, soon five.
Why do you have so many kids?
I'm scared of being alone, I guess.
-Why are you scared of that?
-Well, I'm not. I can be alone.
But I like having kids around me.
I like kids. I love kids.
How many have you slept with?
That's a very personal question.
-Why?
-It's a private matter.
I have to draw a line where...
You can be personal, but not private.
I know exactly how many there are.
Counting them is easy,
but I won't do that here.
-You know how many, but...?
-I don't want to say it.
-You have a talk show.
-Yes.
What's the purpose of it?
The idea is to create
good conversations.
-What does that do?
-It will enlighten and entertain people.
-So it's informative?
-Yes, that too.
Why do you think
that you get to be on TV?
That's a very good question.
I've asked myself the same thing.
Right now I'm thinking Saga Norén
should have had that job instead.
I think you have
a narcissistic personality disorder.
I... Then I would like to use
my power as the host to say...
-...thank you, Saga Norén.
-My pleasure.
-She could have done it.
-Yes.
It would have been an interesting show.
Yes, you'd get to know quite a lot.
Absolutely. I would have kept up.
Sofia, it's great to have you here.
You can stay with us
a little bit longer.
I want you to listen to
an exciting story we're going to tell.
Thank you, Sofia Helin.